[Musica]
siamo nati raccoglitori e cacciatori non
certo Agricoltori o allevatori e abbiamo
mantenuto stretta noi questa ricchezza
questa attitudine per centinaia di anni
per millenni fino addirittura a poche
decine di anni fa io sono
un'antropologia culturale specializzata
in etnobotanica e conservazione per i
più sono una forager che cos'è il
foraging è l'attività di andare a
raccogliere vegetali o parte di essi
selvatici adatti a nutrimento umano
negli ambienti il più incontaminati
possibile a partire dall'altissima
montagna fino ad arrivare al mare il
foraging ci appartiene da sempre prima
dell'industrializzazione e della
globalizzazione alimentare era una cosa
normalissima andare a raccogliere
vegetali selvatici e consumarli era così
normale da essere ritenuta Addirittura
una scienza chiamata alimurgia e
detenuta principalmente dai monaci
persino Leonardo da Vinci inseriva nei
suoi scritti nei suoi appunti
riguardanti la cucina il cibo
l'alimentazione l'utilizzo di tantissimi
ingredienti selvatici come radici frutti
semi licheni funghi cortecce interne d'
alberi resine fino ad arrivare ad
ingredienti inusuali come le uova di
rana un bagaglio culturale enorme che
però stiamo perdendo oggi e perché lo
stiamo perdendo perché siamo abituati ad
avere una sussistenza semplicissima non
abbiamo più bisogno di raccogliere siamo
abituati a procacciarsi del supermercato
dal frigorifero di casa nostra dal menù
di un ristorante e quindi perché oggi
dovremmo riavvicinarci al foraging
perché dovremmo considerare questa
disciplina perché dovremmo addirittura
pensare di insegnarla magari anche a
scuola ci sono
diverse ci sono diverse motivazioni la
più scontata e quella più logica è che
attraverso il foraging noi possiamo
riabbracciare La nostra identità
alimentare e insieme ad essa l'identità
culturale che ci appartiene attraverso
uno dei rapporti più solidi più diretti
e più complessi che abbiamo con gli
elementi intorno a noi il cibo di cui
abbiamo scelto di nutrirci
la seconda il secondo motivo è semplice
il cibo selvatico è gratis quindi è
accessibile e disponibile per tutti noi
siamo abituati a un sistema alimentare
che ci ha proposto che non è abituato a
questa forma di gratuità anzi molto
spesso avvalora molto di più il
commercio il denaro svantaggi il
benessere umano e quello ambientale ma
non dobbiamo nemmeno dimenticarci che
per noi la sussistenza è facile come
dicevo poco fa ma per tante persone nel
mondo Circa un terzo del pianeta è è
davvero difficile e quindi il cibo
selvatico diventa una risorsa enorme che
però va studiata e analizzata per essere
usata la terza motivazione ci apre gli
orizzonti della Nutraceutica della
Nutrizione e del sapore avete mai
provato una carota selvatica la daucus
carota il predecessore della carota
coltivata è brutta è orribile da vedere
è bianca beige sporca di terra è molto
diversa dalle carote a cui siamo
abituati perfette lisce enormi arancioni
pensate che sono arancioni in omaggio
alla dinastia degli Orange che è stata
una dei più grandi produttori
commercianti di carote nel mondo ma se
proviamo la carota selvatica Allora sì
che arriviamo alla vera essenza di
questo ortaggio sempr sentiamo un sapore
così forte da sembrarci quasi ostile
pazzesco stessa cosa con la fragola
selvatica è piccola bruttina si
schiaccia durante il trasporto Eppure
quando la proviamo sì che sentiamo il
sapore di fragola vera ed anche forse un
pochino quello del luogo di origine la
foresta la quarta motivazione è la mia
preferita è quella che sta nel mio cuore
ed è quella ambientale fare foraging Ci
obbliga a conoscere tutta una serie di
di altre discipline che vanno dalla
geografia alla Botanica all'et Botanica
all'ecologia Ci obbliga a conoscere gli
ecosistemi e le dinamiche che li muovono
quindi fare far jinga ci invita ad avere
un rapporto più sinergico più umano più
vicino all'ambiente naturale molto più
simile a quello che avevano i nostri avi
infatti in tutte le culture e per
millenni la biosfera è stata considerata
un pianeta vivente completa di spirito
una creatura viva Che respirava
caratterizzata organica con un aspetto
organico piena di coscienza ritenuta
sacra celebrata e venerata come una dea
gli antichi Greci La chiamavano Gea gli
AB origini australiani kun Pipi il mio
popolo il popolo Sami mataraca i popoli
Andini pachamama in tutti i culti legati
alla celebrazione della terra il fil
Rouge il punto più importante era la
coscienza della presenza dell'essere
umano all'interno della natura e dei
suoi complessi meccanismi non al di
sopra di essa all'interno della natura
stessa la natura era rispettata era
sacra era ritenuta sacra perché dava i
frutti per nutrire l'essere umano lo
idrat con la sua acqua generava l'aria
che veniva respirata era necessaria e in
quanto necessaria quindi sacra poi con
le prime riforme protestanti le
filosofie di Cartesio e Bacone le prime
teorie scientifiche è arrivato il
progresso E con esso una veloc un
velocissimo miglioramento delle
condizioni della civiltà ma anche un
velocissimo degrado dei valori
fondamentali del rispetto per il pianeta
e del ruolo dell'uomo inserito nel
complesso meccanismo della nostra
biosfera Madre Terra da entità venerata
e onorata è diventata un mero oggetto di
conquista Di nostra proprietà Io credo
che tutti dovremmo allontanarci un po'
da questo atteggiamento utilitaristico
nei confronti dell'ambiente naturale e
Dovremmo cercare di riavvicinarci a un
rapporto più mutualistico nei confronti
della natura più simile a quello dei
nostri avi e credo anche che discipline
semplici come il foraging possano
aiutarci a riconnetterci con l'ambiente
in fondo fare foraging equivale quasi a
metterci un paio di occhiali
potentissimi che ci rendono capaci di
focalizzare e di fare uno zoom sui
singoli dettagli che compongono tutto
quello che sta intorno a noi e quindi
entrare nell'ambiente naturale diventa
un'avventura che ci riempie di
esplorazione di stupore avvicinarci
all'ambiente in fondo significa
avvicinarci a noi stessi sentire il
bisogno che abbiamo di riconnetterci con
l'ambiente naturale possiamo vedere il
nostro ruolo su questo pianeta
sentendoci più Uri ad ogni passo
consapevoli di essere parte di questa
grande
[Applauso]
meraviglia